okay so team Gary has made a lot of
content over the years but what's your
favorite piece of content that was made
a great question
my favorite content by far is I'm
considering doing a banner media
operation stay-at-home day once a week
forever because I'm I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day then
sometimes in a month here's the
punchline like [ __ ] like it's the
words out of my mouth not the [ __ ]
camera quality good news about the Sony
[ __ ] interesting dick if you are
fortunate enough to be watching this
right now and not being somebody who's
lost a loved one because of this or who
doesn't have somebody on a ventilator no
matter how much business you lost back
to Katy's question about like being an
influencer then your restaurant being
close money doesn't mean [ __ ] when you
somebody you love the most in the world
dies and so this is perspective time be
grateful for what you have
don't cry about what's changed it's
devastating for seniors that miss out on
their prom and graduation I understand
that's your world but I promise you
thank God that everybody in your family
is okay focus on the good focus on the
gratitude because if you watch the news
all day if you go on social all day
you're gonna get to fear
everything's [ __ ] blah yeah get your
[ __ ] mind right
make sure Corona got your mind right
you do not love losing you lost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Dustin I'm a
videographer for Team Gary Vee
Gary wanted to go live on Facebook every
single morning which then became as you
know tea with Gary Vee I usually handle
a lot of Gary's livestream stuff and his
podcasts setups and stuff like that we
had to figure out how to make this work
remotely I'm gonna teach you how to do
that later in this episode but first
watch this clip from Monday's episode of
tea with Gary Vee
how are you I'm excellent I'm excellent
it's pretty amazing actually to be able
to be on call with you so I'm pretty
excited about that what's cooking well
you saw my question you know so I I i
sell restaurant point of sale software
so I help restaurant owners you know
make their businesses more efficient
help them run their business grow their
sales and so forth and then with this
shutdown man it's it's just affecting
all of them and so I'm just curious as
to what ideas you might have for them to
help them through it I mean for them
they've got a got a reengineer their
infrastructure to be able to do local
delivery or we've got the savings to
whether the one hundred twenty-five
hundred
you know this could be for restaurants
and public places you could be looking
at you know 3/4 of a year because even
when we opened back up I think there's
gonna be hesitation from hat you know
it's gonna be a little while for public
places to get all the way back because
even if we open up in three months you
know I know my mom and you know other
people that are like you know kind of
skate scared are gonna be a little less
excited about going you know there'll be
a whole group of that couldn't wait to
go out so they'll be that pent up but I
don't you know could be a little while
before it gets to even-steven so I think
there's two things one they've got to
innovate and they've got to innovate in
two ways from a branding standpoint or
from an operational standpoint either
they build out significant delivery
infrastructure so it's not only
the ability to have door - or ubereats
or you know seamless pickup from them
it's also the ability to have the
capabilities of prepping those meals and
things of that nature but it's also
building up awareness in marketing so
that people choose their restaurant
versus a different one and number two I
think they need to make content if I
owned a restaurant right now in my
restaurant by myself and I would
literally walk if I was a if I was a
owner chef I would literally make a
video of every single dish we have on
the menu tell the world your story I
think of it right now is this
I think the coronavirus has caused us
all to be into one huge virtual campfire
in the [ __ ] 1300 so we need to go
around and tell each other our stories
which is what we used to do pre
television pre [ __ ] everything radio
we used to sit around and tell [ __ ]
stories from the [ __ ] heart and from
the brain and I think every small
business right now needs to tell their
story why they started their business
how they started their business
war stories aka bad things that have
happened hero stories aka great things
that happened and then go in the detail
of their business you know I would walk
around my [ __ ] restaurant be like
here's why we take these chairs I didn't
have any [ __ ] money I bought him at a
garage sale the sign came for like tell
the world your story in the form of 50
videos the end I think everybody should
do that Wow doing over do a belly right
now 98% of people are gonna do out and
the 2% that do and make and create and
go on offense and realize the
opportunity will succeed 10x and that's
the way the game is played
[Music]
thank you for everybody who spent two
hours with me this morning I'm gonna try
to you a bunch of these this week next
week I mean the more corona the more tea
time with Gary so Dustin thank you
unless the team thank you watch this
morning I wish you guys nothing but the
best
much love and ease on and just so you
know it's 9:55 thank you everybody got a
cut tuning up some will do two hours
tomorrow again I think is that right
Dustin is that we yeah okay I got to go
to a finance meeting for Boehner so real
life [ __ ] so let's sneak in for a moment
so first of all thank you very on but
basically my question was if I want to
make it kind of content but I feel might
ostracize me from the people that are
closest to me how do I get over that
fear easy by realizing that anybody who
be ostracized or not like you as much
about you talking about something that
you're passionate and interested in
talking about is somebody that is not
something that you need to be valuing
they need to love gotcha
you all of you all the true of you like
you what are gonna live a fake life like
you know you're gonna maintain friends
and family predicated on things that you
like you're literally not gonna talk
about the things that you want to talk
about in life because you friended your
mom or your uncle or your sister or your
homies are gonna think it's weird or on
a pro inappropriate or like you don't
want that you don't want those
friendships anyway I mean that try
Thomason don't underestimate friends and
family they tend to step up
all right everybody hope you enjoyed
today's episode of team with Gary B I'm
super excited to be doing this show like
when the cheese gets cold by the end I
see life is good [ __ ] - I appreciate all
of you I'll see you tomorrow 9:00 a.m.
Eastern I hope this brought value my
team will now be chopping up a ton of
content we couldn't get out further
throughout the day I love you Dustin
thank you so much let's get quicker on
the ones and twos tomorrow yes sir and I
appreciate all of you have a Bleakley
great great great great day I promise
you we'll look back at this pandemic as
long as you don't lose a loved one as a
good thing it is a reset it is one step
back two steps forward you will find
better jobs you will start better
businesses will learn Pass save you'll
learn how to be grateful for simplicity
I love you all very much we'll see you
soon
[Music]
what's up everybody my name is Jason I'm
the editor of weekly V in this next
scene coming up it's a zoom call the
team does with Gary we do some Q&A and
have a little discussion on how we're
gonna position weekly B this week that
you're watching right now so here it is
check it out and if you have any
feedback leave some comments you know
anything that we can make this show
better so we're doing this guy because I
sent you a text I was like hey we want
to do weekly B or more of questions
towards you do you want to do weekly B
with the tee time plus you recording
selfie videos and you're like hey let's
do this so we have a ton of questions to
record content that's casual so I first
question is weekly V is gonna be tea
time plus these sessions are you cool
yep yes that was what we're to your
point I figured that should not just
have the same visual let's have some Q&A
to fill out like this and are you cool
with this rolling out next Friday or do
you want to just read out the process
because usually we do weekly B the week
prior but this is a little kick next
week I'm okay with next week cool all
right I'll do the first question and
then what kind of bounce around
leveraging self social media in these
times from my
small business it's a very like and big
lluis question but like what do you
think like just from that leveraging
social media in these times from my
small business I don't think I think
that's all that QA was so I don't think
that's gonna add to the if this is
strictly being done for the blog but I
think it meets I think it needs to bring
different value for the blog so I'm not
gonna answer that because it is pretty
what happened and by the way if this is
a complete clunker tonight could be a
good one like I'm not I'm not stressed
to yourself totally I mean there's so
many questions here so by the way I
think that clip right there is probably
what we should put in the book and rod
there we go
me punching you directly in the throat
let's do yeah any advice for people for
losing their jobs right now and they
need to stay afloat or like need some
kind of other source of income or this
time yeah I mean I think you know as I
talked about on today's live stream two
things that stand out is selling [ __ ]
and then going into donation world I've
got really excited hope we clip the
thing where I talked about hey why don't
you perform if you're a singer a dancer
a comedian and put and tag your venmo
thing for donations I have a funny
feeling that could be a monster so my
two things are really a telethon or QVC
literally BG QVC or Jerry Lewis that is
the two things when you're in the
there's three things you can ask okay
email a thousand people if they have a
job for you you when your back is in the
corner there's there's kind of two ways
to go about it offense and defense
defense is literally texting on earth
and on LinkedIn you have a job for me
that's what I do that's the offense
offense to me comes in two forms QVC you
know as you saw today and for a lot of
people a lot of people have a lot of
even people that are not making a lot of
money have a mass this is America
it's a materialistic society we just
have a lot of [ __ ]
so a QVC aka selling on eBay Macari
you know coach post Poshmark Facebook
marketplace or be telethon go live on
Instagram pin your pin your venmo and
[ __ ] dance simple people give you
some money like a PBS great bigger this
one's this one's from Instagram I'm like
what are you doing personally to kind of
keep your energy up during during this
crisis two things one I'm doing virtual
workouts with Mike McCarthy so last two
days put in some real work and like
we're gonna miss so I'm excited about
that little exercise physical energy and
then I spend my life 18 you know it's 15
to 18 hours a day in parallel to
whatever the [ __ ] I'm doing even while
I'm doing this I'm in mental perspective
land gratitude gratitude gratitude I
continue to expose the energy that
everybody that outside of a family that
as an individual is passed away from
this this has the potential to be a
remarkable opportunity for East set
towards happiness I understand people
may lose jobs
I understand people may lose money but I
think if you really play with this and
put into perspective and gratitude an
opportunity you will realize that this
can also become a time of a reset that
leads you towards a life of happiness
instead of unhappiness with financial
success and I believe happiness with
financial okayness
is dramatically more exciting than than
unhappiness with financial success
right I just thought of a question for
you
thank you distant since we're doing this
in its low quality and I know you've
brought it up before like during the
actual livestream and now we're kind of
resorting to this like just want to talk
about that since like we're going from
like a really high production weekly be
now - like majority to this and just the
fact that it's blowing up like it's
starting to get like because the
production value doesn't mean [ __ ] right
sometimes and I think that's an
important addition to my conversation
right I'm glad that I said sometimes
because like when you're making avatar
and Star Wars it does matter
but I think 99 percent of people
watching this video right now I need to
realize you're not [ __ ] George Lucas
and like everybody buying like like stop
being that tennis player I was make fun
of that bought the [ __ ] Federer
sneakers in the foul racket and the John
McEnroe [ __ ] headband and you spend
$8,000 on equipment but you [ __ ] blow
at tennis you lost six nothing to a guy
with a wooden racket that's how I think
about production I don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know special effects
I don't need my lighting to be proper
you and I just so we're talking about
this earlier like like if we use this
clip you're [ __ ] lighting looks like
[ __ ] you're behind a [ __ ] window
right now I don't know why mine looks
good behind a window right now I think
you might have fixed the camera when you
did the husband thing but like here's
the punchline like [ __ ] like it's the
words out of my mouth not the [ __ ]
camera quality good news Gary me I got
to Sony [ __ ] six nine four I gotta
get my [ __ ]
it's still not gonna make you
interesting dick that's why Dustin it's
not the [ __ ] production value it's
the [ __ ] value out of your [ __ ]
mouth it's the value out of the pictures
when you're in the information business
it's the information Oh
would the production add to it yes do we
do better if this has a good thumbnail
and a good title yes
I'm late on the record I currently do
not like our thumbnails currently I
understand that we're talking to YouTube
rep and they're probably more on I don't
know I don't see us doing so remarkably
well that I think that our best practice
really like but that's what's cool about
it
that's my subjectiveness Jim Jake Jason
hey Kate you might like it might not
like it it's all funny that's what I
like about it but
maybe I'll say I didn't like how like
bad I looked in the last photo exactly
the thing but like nonetheless it what
I'm saying is production images a lot of
those things are gonna be so subjective
and people spend all their time on it
even the words on your mouth are
subjective to me spending 90% of your
energy on your opinion on how good the
quality is what [ __ ] people up okay
well what was the impetus of you
reserving the time to go live five days
a week this week um two things one value
for an audience of value for myself as
you know Andy more than anybody in the
world maybe besides maybe P Rock I've
been wanting to do tea with Gary B for
[ __ ] seven years four years two years
like I've been on this kick of doing a
morning show where I drink tea and
[ __ ] answer questions and so I've
always wanted to do this and then and
then number two at the time and number
three I knew that I was gonna bring
value I'll be honest with you I've been
surprised how good I mean I've been you
know I'm not rushed about two hours
today like you guys have seen you guys
know more than anybody right I'm even
looking at your head nods like you guys
know the version of me doing this show
right now I mean Jim thank you for the
compliment sends me such a nice text
like like I'm really I'm really hitting
a tone right now I agree I thought it
would bring out good content you know
and I thought it'd bring value and like
reading my Twitter stream and like
reading my DMS and emails like I've
helped some people already yeah this is
really good clip that we brought up in
our 4:30 content meeting yesterday that
I pitched as a creation which was you
ranting about doing it for the user
everyone comes up with ideas about
trying to sell products and stuff but
it's not how to act its self-interested
and just seem really relevant to what
you're doing right now and start doing
it for the user always bro so what we do
better than anybody in the world I gotta
go to my next meeting because I'm still
operating by late vlog I'm operating my
business like I've been 12 hours a day
on calls I've never I've been operating
like a [ __ ]
so I got to bounce out of here I hope
you're enjoying the blog here's some
more clips and I'll keep doing this a
team that
to be an ocular so how are we doing tea
with Gary B I'm gonna show you right now
as you can tell I'm wearing my very nice
clothes but I'm gonna show you we're
gonna go quick step by step basic idea
basic gist of how this is done and this
took me a lot of different tries a lot
of googling a lot of you tubing but
you're about to see okay so basically
three different software's that you
mainly need just for this part one
Lubeck audio this for audio zoom because
that's how we get the video and the
meeting going and OBS which is a
broadcasting software so how we do it
first I create a new meeting and you
just hit join with computer audio that's
me hello I send this over here
unfortunately I don't have someone to
test this meeting with right now so you
just get the basic idea of like this is
where Gary would pop up right here Gary
would pop up right here on this screen
my second monitor and then you and we
invite people one by one into the
meeting see how I'm the only one here
right now and then Gary talks to them
this is basically then fed into
where's my bar okay there we go
this is fit into linked and this is then
linked into OBS and that's me right
there see how I could see it so none of
this stuff displays because I just have
the way I have this set up so see now we
don't see it anymore then we have OBS to
be keyed and linked to restream which is
this I'm not sure if you should be
showing this Jason but uh you might want
to blur this out just in case
so then anyway OBS goes to restream and
that is how it's done but as far as I
think this is the part where everyone
really doesn't really know what's going
on is the zoom part and it's actually
really simple it's just as simple as the
hosts of this meeting but I turn my
video off making Gary the host
essentially even though the zoom hosts
but Gary is the host and then we just
have guests come on one at a time we
could see so and then we have guests
come in here one at a time and I just
asked them to join the meeting by asking
them to enable their video that's pretty
much the idea I'm gonna make a full
video about this because a lot of people
have been asking how it's done step by
step so then you'll buy you'll see that
soon probably on LinkedIn
sure ok bye so we're just gonna go one
by one add some questions and it'll be
some weekly be content let's do it all
right cool well apparently five years
ago some TX do this question it was what
was your spirit animal and you said ran
man from he-man
an exit again has anything changed what
would you say is your spirit animal what
is this Bowman here at animal um
probably
our koala bears aggressive and fuzzy and
soft but also has like well actually you
know it's funny that's how I see myself
but I don't think a lot of people you
might content it's almost like people
that view my content actually view it as
like harder on the inside but you guys
know it's soft and you know it's kind of
like a tootsie roll pop you know what
the tootsie roll pop out last question
from me if you could switch roles with
anyone on our team who would it be in
why oh great question who would I switch
roles with on the team and why I would
probably switch roles with it's a really
good question
I would probably switch roles with Zayn
because I and I'm not even sure he's
really actually doing this but what he
was hired to do or theoretically and I
know it evolves is I love community
management like if I if I could and by
the way to remind everybody who's
watching this vlog the way I became Gary
B was replying to every single tweet on
Twitter for real eight nine hours a day
for four years like people don't get it
like people don't get it you you guys as
a team know how I work so you're like
maybe know the answers for real like if
I could reply to every single two one
two nine three one five seven three one
and every comment on Instagram right now
and tick tock and Twitter I mean I would
that would make me so happy if that was
fifteen hours of my day and so you know
I would say Zayn in theory cuz he's
supposed to be doing can be a management
though I'm not sure keys that's awesome
that's not who I expected thing
indie-rock for some reason but he Brock
would be like the last person I don't
love to film other people and I don't
love being overrated
kidding all right that's it for me
next up who's on the list or Nestle are
you personally being more careful with
social distancing right now yeah I've
been quarantine for [ __ ] month
you haven't been out at all no I'm
guilty I've left yeah I'm like I'm not
you know what honestly like I want to
see my parents during this time like I'm
signed up for like four to eight weeks
and so I'd rather not go out and see
anybody so I can see my folks if I want
to go visit them and know that route so
that's been the main reason you say you
always love being around people and
noise chaos
so what's it been what's the past two
weeks been shockingly good because as
you guys know you know if you look at my
calendar I've been busy as [ __ ] like
I've been going hard for 1112 like I'm
getting so much [ __ ] done like I'm
I'm considering doing a vaynermedia
operation stay-at-home day once a week
forever because I'm I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day then
sometimes in a month
like I this has been a huge eye-opener
for me I thought this was gonna be the
worst like I mean I like spending more
time with you guys in this ten minutes
zoom call like seeing avatars really
excites me like I'm like I'm like I'm
enjoying it being super productive I I'm
keepin I've been on phone calls for and
Zing's and Google Hangouts for 12 hours
a day straight with no breaks
so I'm [ __ ] feeling great that's all I
got next
the you're in the famous USC feature
first opener was I don't think
entrepreneurship is teachable and that's
been like a model for a lot of people do
you think the same way about leadership
do you think leadership is not as
teacher was entrepreneurship is the
answer is yes to both but then let's
talk
this I don't think that let's actually
separate them entrepreneurship requires
a minimum level of ability to actually
be successful no different than being an
athlete or being a musician like not
everybody actually is good enough to
actually be a professional musician and
a professional athlete and no level of
teaching courses watching videos and
practice can get you there I actually
believe that to be true about
entrepreneurship you can watch all my
videos all day long you can do you can
learn what have you to go to business
school but if it's not your natural
talent there is a potential there's a
pot there's a likelihood that you're not
able to build a sustainable life happy
and successful where there's a little
hedge there is I actually counter myself
because I think making 87,000 a year
having a peanut butter startup is
brilliant but for most people that would
be deemed as not successful enough for
entrepreneurship so it's a funny way for
me to answer it I think entrepreneurship
is a talent I think leadership is a
talent and like any other talent in the
world you can get better at it I could
be a better skier than I am today cuz I
don't practice and I don't watch videos
and I don't follow skiers can I be
better yes I think the problem with
entrepreneurship is that people think
that going to the Olympics every time
they start a business so we need more
realism leadership similar no different
you know what to sing do I think all of
you are better leaders because you rub
elbows with me yes do I think all of you
are better entrepreneurs cuz you rebels
with me no so I think it's different I
think a lot of you already but actually
very fun to tie these things together a
lot of you nodded your heads when I
talked about like how soft I actually am
versus the hyper nature competitive kind
of like you know the stand-up comedian I
am in my content
oh you all responded pretty well as I
was looking at your videos I'm a
likeable good leader I'm showing it in
this crisis I'm showing it other times I
think you guys are better now because of
that then you'll take that as parents as
leaders in the future you've learned
things for me I can see it I can see it
in Andy I can see Roxy and you can see
it that's it I could see it already um I
don't think that means that you're gonna
be and I and I do think that's different
than entrepreneurship I think you've
been around me and I don't think you
guys have become better entrepreneurs
per se maybe there's some things that
you know to look out for or maybe
there's some more self-awareness but not
better
whereas I do think you're better leaders
so I do think leadership is more
teachable than successful
entrepreneurial operations well what so
what the thousand person company that
basically went like immediately what are
some rising things that about building
that infrastructure that you noticed
what's been what's what's on your mind
with that I guess well not actually
let's go any other way the reason it's
going so well is the least surprising
thing to me of all time because when you
actually build culture and a family and
people give a [ __ ] about each other this
is when it shows it is what a what an
opportunity in my blog to give an
enormous shout out so the mark yard kids
are the word the clogs the Allens the
Marcus and the lease is the next Judy's
the Avis like the leadership of Boehner
X you know James and Jeff Nichols and
Lee and Ryan Harwood Mary Kate like the
leadership man coded leadership at
Boehner accident ear underneath em we
said helps the world like like like
Linda H is like like the leadership
Saturday and on and on the leadership of
this company absorb this challenge
remarkably well Wanda and Sarah Murphy
like just like we're [ __ ] crushing it
now we're a modern company that's built
on the cloud so all our infrastructure
technology wise is easy right we give a
[ __ ] about each other so people are
being empathetic and kind and worried
about while I'm sitting and like
worrying about like making payroll and
like fixing everything for all the lost
revenue and all the clients were losing
real stuff like my team is worried about
like people sending emails saying they
feel burned out because they're getting
too many emails and I'm like
[ __ ] I'm saving your jobs have
you complained about but that's but
everybody plays their role right and
what's been the biggest surprise the
lack of surprise the the biggest
surprise is an anti surprise I [ __ ]
knew it
when you actually build a family and you
build culture you know you're ready for
the war this is a [ __ ] war and we're
[ __ ] standing up do you think that
companies that started out remote can do
that like do you think the reason I
[ __ ] did that is because it was I
think they could you know like I like it
you know I mean I want to sit on top of
you guys if I could squeeze all you into
my office I would so I like that [ __ ]
but I will say this I feel super cozy on
zooms and Google Hangouts with clients
I've never met before so don't you know
I never underestimate technology but I
do love interpersonal I think they're
both amazing and I do think a lot of
companies are gonna be more remote and
do more remote so I'll tell you one
thing for sure there's a lot of times
when I want to do a meeting and I have
to wait till I fly to Cincinnati that
now I tell my admins put it on Zoom put
it on Google Hangouts like I'm
definitely starting to build the cadence
a feeling comfortable in this
environment getting my cadence down
because I like you guys know me I pick
up on everything so I like being in a
room and seeing stuff like I don't even
like that there's some people on this
call like I don't see Danny and Cheryl
on the screen up the top now and I don't
[ __ ] like it because I need to see
all what are you doing and what do you
do you know like like you know because
the way my screen is up top all of us
are missing two of the people at the top
with the way the zoom bill or maybe
actually if you did gallery review you
can't wait to see all of us [ __ ] go
this is huge
I may never go into the office again
this is the monster moment I'm not
kidding like like seeing Cheryl laughing
right now and seeing the thing behind
Danny's back like I need context which
is why I like in person but technology
is getting better to where I'm getting
the context a little bit more
like I'm pumped like I think I'm gonna
be I think you know I'm devastated for
every single life lost of Corona
but I'm don't give a [ __ ] about the
money and I think we come out stronger
and I think I come out stronger and
Boehner comes out stronger a lot of
people come out stronger more self-aware
try new things it's [ __ ] amazing
awesome my next life I apologize thing
like I would argue right now that I even
just brainstorm do I want to Gary to do
a one day a week work from home but they
have to be unzoom the whole time in the
background of what they're working and
well that actually make us even more of
a team not less and of course people put
music in and new people out of course
like somebody like if I was part of it
I'd be at the whole time like I get it
but like you know like I'm I'm in the
meeting this is the time to innovate and
I'm excited about it they may take over
all right and bringing kind of a
different perspective so someone that
has like small nastic I know you're
always talking about saving money and
setting stuff aside and it's the reason
how cool that just got all of a sudden
when I was making when everybody else
was talking about no don't save money
and put it all into play and like like
you know you only live one said [ __ ]
you know put it all into the market and
leverage you know all of a sudden
everybody loved that and I was like
boring like it's gonna take 22 years and
say money and at least I was charismatic
in a different way so me me but let's
talk and twist it 20 people hated the
[ __ ] I was saying it's amazing how in a
week everyone's like wait a minute yeah
so listen has like a chunk of money
maybe five ten thousand dollars what do
they do with it now just sit on it do
they invest rocks are under priced
stocks are under price 18 months gonna
be better than they are right now don't
buy [ __ ] Amazon go buy Netflix go buy
Facebook every secondary Mart like
sports cards are still gonna be
explosive in the summer in the winter
and guess what prices are down like I
can't wait I'm so busy right now
but I can't wait to like maybe late next
week like maybe not this weekend but the
next week
finally settles in a little bit to like
spend eight or ten hours buy a ton of
[ __ ] cuz things are down um everything's
gonna be [ __ ] down
if you have money right now you've got
leverage but right up this minute for
this vlog when it airs I would argue by
the way you know I said we can wait a
week Jason for this vlog to come out I
would argue that we need it to be as
time-sensitive as possible so if it
comes out on Tuesday I know we were
going for that Friday thing but the
right thing is for this to come out on
Monday then I'm cool with that just
effort instead of waiting because I just
thought of Caceres next Friday [ __ ] the
way the world's moving so quickly like
[ __ ] to change so anyway so then yeah I
I think that you know coming out of this
I could see real estate I can see other
things going down in pricing like
there's a lot about to happen but right
this second
like I mean I don't know what did the
stock market do today say yesterday went
up like crazy today
it is absolutely 500 points like we have
stock like like I just think stock
I think stock is definitely under priced
compared to where it's going to be if
you have five to ten thousand bucks and
you're okay with looking at what it's
worth in 24 months I don't think
flipping stuff I think premium sneakers
premium cards you know cards they're
down I think I think yeah those two
standout and then you know five to ten
thousand you only look this is how crazy
this is there's gonna be some businesses
you can buy for ten thousand bucks that
were making a hundred thousand in profit
but the owner was selling t-shirts on
Instagram and she or he was was spending
on 220 thousand and now they need to get
the [ __ ] they need twenty thousand real
quick to just like get out of their
situation and you can buy their business
for twenty thousand bucks yeah okay I
have a special guest she was like super
excited to be on my mom let's go ask you
a question hi Gary it's nice to meet you
too because I've been hearing about you
for
years and it's exciting to see her
actually make this happen and be out
there and I appreciate your mentorship
so my question for you is talking about
with you talking about
organizations being able to convert
working from home yeah I'm I'm a
retention executive at Dish Network okay
and within 24 hours our call center
sanitized everything and sent equipment
home with people that have never worked
from home you turned it around and we
are so productive right now it's amazing
to see what's happening to you on do you
ever get out into businesses like that
and actually spend the time on the
ground looking at other organizations
and what's happening for instance
someplace like Dish Network which I'd
love to invite you to come to our site
so first of all listen first of all Amy
you know just by the relational you know
we're family now so the answer is I'm
telling Daniel right now to listen to
this like she need to talk to my admins
and if I'm in Phoenix for some reason I
will be there I will not even addition
to any trip and I will find a reason to
be a big scene later as far as do i I am
a learner through osmosis it's less
likely for me to go see how Disney does
it for Netflix does it or dip doesn't
two good things one this chapter my
career goes to service big companies so
by nature I've walked into Chase and yo
geo and Budweiser and Hulu and have seen
what you're talking about so one of the
great reasons I wanted to do vaynermedia
was I knew that it was going to I was
gonna get paid to walk into businesses
and because I'm a multi-dimensional
thinker I could do my job while in the
corner of my eye watch how they do that
they do the reception or how they do
these things so through the osmosis of
what I do for a living it's naturally
happened yes
so Gary of all the things that has
happened since chromeless truck what has
made you the happiest
what like little tiny thing if it's like
looking outside of flowers or something
I played a shitload of football with my
little guy and so those are moments I
wouldn't have had they've grown a dim
hit so that is number one in real life
in macro Gary me talk people have
learned so much about themselves in the
last eight days every single person I
think on has actually created a new
insight about themselves that they did
not know how this does not happen that
might be by the way for some people
that's a bad thing
not a bad thing limit plays there's some
people that's gonna be a step backwards
for two steps forwards where they
realize something you know for many
others it's gonna be a positive I will
tell you that I never thought working
from home was in my cards ever to the
day I died I now know it is that's
exciting
like that means 52 year old Gary can
take an entire summer off and be on the
beach and be productive as [ __ ] that's
kind of cool I don't know if I like that
then you know so like I my favorite
little thing is just a very big thing
because that's how I roll people are
just going to be able to learn about
themselves more because of this and I
think I think a stunning amount of good
comes out of this I really do if you
look at it twenty years from now I
believe that I really believe it um okay
so team Gary has made a lot of content
over the years what is your I know you
don't necessarily watch all of all of it
but what's your favorite piece of
content it was make a great question
my favorite content by far is the
content that has my family in it because
I know what it's like I thought about
that photo you guys know that photo
where I kissed my dad hard on the side
of his face in the parking lot
that was what came first to mind the
fact that there's a video version of
that moment I'm pumped I'm really pumped
like emotionally pumped about that so
probably that one of the other things
while just to give you full transparency
the blueberry piece of content is a big
one
because I think that got like three
million views or something like that on
Instagram so good remarkably all-time
well at the time but it was also one of
the earliest pieces of me doing
something outside of me and just showing
human me so that was like a fun
observation I love that piece of content
there's a lot boy I'm really grateful
you know it's funny my answer about my
dad is a micro answer to the macro I am
documented guys do you know much better
my documentary is gonna be in 1637 years
and everybody else's because there's
gonna be unlimited content to pick from
you know this this is [ __ ] cool like
do you I just you like this is important
I want the seven of you to understand
this you will watch this exact video in
49 years you know like your your great
niece is gonna like communicate with you
with whatever the texting of the day is
and then is going to say that's cool
yeah so like all of it my dad Chris
photo and video definitely definitely
the blueberry thing stands out the ramp
and the white t-shirt for during for the
diploma stuff the you could have been a
[ __ ] bus
the one where I like get into that
conversation with that woman about
cursing you know
uh what the worst-performing finders cuz
we need that humility so that feels good
I you know just there's all the [ __ ]
feels good this is the best part like
this is why I think I'm the ultimate
creator like it's all good
[ __ ] the analytics [ __ ] the numbers like
all of it's part of the [ __ ] entire
work of art so I've got it's like
children after one of these pieces of
content like [ __ ] showing I [ __ ]
love them all when they underperform
when they over perform the the Jets
sweater video the Larry King interview
and a lot of [ __ ] those are like
highlights on the high but on the low I
mean it like when I the post I did two
or three days ago where we didn't title
it was the tick tock that I just posted
as an Instagram that I just felt like I
had to do it it was the right message
but sure enough it underperformed
because it wasn't contextually
post-produced
or an Instagram and I was a good Gary
take that [ __ ] L you [ __ ] you think
you know you think it's just message not
production well here right in your
[ __ ] face tick you know I think I
like that game with myself
you guys same thing is last time we're
gonna do some Q&A
let's go fast all right we're starting
with May here we go oh gee you often say
for you what's the difference between
the two can you go you when you're not
being cuz you're making noise we're
walking through you look amazing by the
way Caleb I love just go on mute while
we go so you don't say positivity and
optimism but what do you think is the
difference between the two since you
said pop the other day positivity and
optimism not to be honest with you may
and this is what's fun about this blog
first of all hi everybody who's watching
the blog we tried to mix in some of this
to make this week's weekly be more
interesting so thanks for joining us you
just saw Caleb this note some crazy [ __ ]
Jesus Christ anyway this is fun actually
I have not given enough thought on how I
think about the difference between
positivity and optimism and I'm not
quite sure how I think about them deeply
optimism to me is like hope
like I see it like I think it can and
positivity is like be happy and like do
good like so there is something there
but I'm gonna spend some more time on
that may and I'll get back to you thank
you so Gary uh tomorrow sell stuff
Saturday people want to know what are
you gonna be posting tomorrow to sell
I'm gonna probably be um you know I
unlike a lot of people do not have you
know cash flow issues because I've been
saving money so I am not feeling as
desperate to sell something however to
build up hype tomorrow heavily for it I
will I I went to my parents house that's
where I am now
to get out of the city so I'll probably
like find some old stuff that I had in
my house to sell my parents have plenty
of my old stuff I'll probably mainly be
promoting wine texts and wine because my
dad always feels really happy when I'm
building up his business for him when
I'm around him so we'll figure some [ __ ]
out but I'm really excited about it if
you're watching this on Friday or
Saturday today or tomorrow is sell stuff
Saturday something I came up with TN
Gary vo will probably be meta maybe we
should come be in the book and weekly be
showing you oh actually right we're not
doing this today I apologize so sell
stuff Saturday has already happened when
you've seen this weekly blog Jason are
we gonna do Tuesday or Wednesday Jason
Tuesday was it awesome
so though this last Saturday was still
sell stuff Saturday here's some
highlights of what people sold hey
everyone my name is Zane I'm a proud
community slash channel manager for Team
Gary this past Saturday we did something
really cool called sell stuff Saturday
how this all came about was last week
there was a tea with Gary BIA so it was
Gary and a really cool caller talked
about how he could increase his spending
by just selling stuff around his home
that he doesn't need anymore
things like clothes and bike this other
common household items and so this past
Saturday we created a challenge slash
event called the sell stuff Saturday and
people from all around the world came
out
and just sold stuff from around their
homes to increase their savings and we
saw a lot of cool things from it you
know people made 5060 hundred dollars is
selling clothes from around their home
we saw one person I think he bought a
video game an n64 classic video game for
75 bucks sold it for 600 which is insane
and one gentleman even made like twenty
three hundred dollars just selling
things from his house and so you know if
you want to go see what it's all about
if you want to get motivated
check out hashtag sell stuff Saturday on
Twitter to see what it's all about and
if you want to flip and get into the
game please tag team giri be on twitter
you want to follow along and see how one
for ya yeah kara so I always ask you
this kind of stuff you know personally
when we hang out but on a holistic view
what do you think are gonna be the
cultural impacts after kovetz past what
do you think's gonna stick remoteness I
I mean I'm the most anti remote person
right no work from home no you know cuz
I I'm already just five days in feeling
very close to you guys right now the
intimacy of like obviously I know your
kitchen Justin but like Caleb and his
spot is it like you know remoteness will
stick some percentage of remoteness like
I'm even debating doing one day a month
from home just doing zoom meetings
operationally because I've been very
effective in the office like I see you
like I'm like I don't know it's been
very good so remoteness
I think delivery what's up sis hey
weekly be this my sister Liz novella
she is a real estate agent if you're
buying homes in New York New Jersey you
need to give her one Oh Anna let's do a
little pop up with her handle right here
all right get out of here listen um part
of this team you're out you're out
ah so so I think remoteness will stick I
think delivery I think a lot of people
have bought you know Tomatoes crayons
for the first time obviously a lot of
people use Amazon Prime but I think a
lot of people are by the way we're gonna
be here for another three four or five
six we like like I think people gonna
get used to buying things on the
internet that they used to go to the
store to and realize they like that so I
think direct-to-consumer
you know is gonna stick buying on the
internet it's gonna stick remoteness is
gonna stick I think people are gonna
figure out their relationships these
combined homes with friends and family
like mainly with family
I think people gonna I think some
relationships are gonna break up and
that's gonna stick I think some
relationships are gonna get better and
that's gonna stick I think some new
hobbies are gonna happen you know I
think people gonna pick up a thing or
two that's gonna stick I think
perspective is gonna stick I think a lot
of people gonna be grateful for their
relationships their friends their loved
ones when they finally get to hug like
I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of each one
of you when I see you and I barely see
you guys which is the weirdest thing
right but there's something about it
so a lot of shits gonna stick brother a
lot of businesses that we speak with
these days everyone's really doing a
good job of like running their business
and making millions of dollars over the
last few years and stuff like that but
they have not really been focusing a lot
on social so how can they use this time
to learn about it and what what would
you do if you were an entrepreneur that
was running a successful business but
then have any social media what would be
the first few things that you would do
then it's really funny you know this
about me my advice is no different than
like a really good health and wellness
versus exercise and eat well like I'm
not gonna change anything like like I
know that almost 90% of people watching
this right now knew what the answer was
gonna be it's just doing this is about
doing and educating yourself what would
I do in more tangible sense I would go
on YouTube and Google search and I would
search how do I post I would go very
very literal how do lawyers make money
on Instagram and I would read 20 things
how do I get clients for my real estate
investment firm through social media
enter and I would I would I would spend
20 hours of deep consumption because if
they're consuming me they're getting the
philosophical strategy the way I give
tactical strategy is through our decks
that we put out put up a link right now
of the pier you know the model and the
company and through yelling at people
watch what I do not what I say right
that's my my way to be tactical is watch
what I do not what I say and
occasionally come out
deck that's super [ __ ] detailed but
there's a lot of people who like
whiteboards and like charts and [ __ ]
like that and that's how they teach and
I would consume that and then build up
the courage to make but this is a mental
[ __ ] game I'm a lawyer I can't be
silly on tik-tok you can i mother I
don't I don't know how to dance I'll
take that because everybody's [ __ ]
excuse watch what I do I don't [ __ ]
dance
[Music]
that's Anandi I'm gonna go that's
because I asked last time cool Caleb
right Gary one of the trending hashtags
is the more you know so like just like a
quick fun fact that you feel like would
be relevant and the time like this note
the more you know yourself the more
happy you will be self-awareness is one
of the greatest gifts of all time don't
be embarrassed with who you are love
what you are and lean into it
period and a story you're not
detail-oriented who gives a [ __ ]
you're awesome you're you're not
creative who gives a [ __ ] you're not
like [ __ ] the more you know yourself
and every I watch people try to disguise
what they suck at right instead of
leaning into what they're great at thank
you so I know you do the 180 strategy
and I love it is there anything else
that we should be doing right now
besides just having patients and put
them into work on Instagram to grow it
to grow Instagram up collaborations live
I like collaborations like going on
somebody's page who's smaller than you
analyzing them and then DMing them and
saying hey let's do a collab because you
know what really everybody wants to go
to somebody he's bigger than that yeah
like everybody wants to go to somebody
like people have like 400 people upwards
of followers DMing me me like Gary B we
should do a collaboration and like cool
like I'm funny I have the humility to do
that but they're not giving me any other
reason then it would help them and I'm
all about charity me lewb
sending masks all over the place left
and right I'm quiet about my charity but
I love charity but don't come at me with
like that's just a weak hub like go
analyze somebody I mean like hey let's
do a live together right I'll go live
and I'll bring you in and we'll both be
live like let's do a live together and
like shoot the [ __ ] I'm a baker
you're a cookie maker let's talk I'm a
florist you're your landscaper let's do
something together like go find somebody
smaller than you and do a collab you
cross pollinate
two people with 80 people following them
give each other 20 followers from a
collab live now you're 80 to 100 I love
the game of building so that's one
becoming more educated like are you
doing polls and stickers on your
Instagram stories like like if you're
not doing stories perfect main feed
perfect and interim live perfect you're
not doing Instagram perfect or you're
not doing it well and so like a
realizing there's three factors in
Instagram and make sure you're focusing
on all three a lot of people are just
one-dimensional right now they only do
the main feed or they only do the main
feed of one live once a lumen per day or
two use stories because it's stackable
but they don't post in the main feed or
but when they do stories they haven't
learned all the filters or the or the
all the you know overlaid stickers the
sticker culture of Instagram stories is
amazing we kind of suck at it that's
another thing I want to talk about
there's so much opportunity for polls
and questions and quizzes and like we
need to get way more creative as a
matter of fact [ __ ] I just got motivated
like let's get thirty minutes on just
Instagram stickers next week the whole
team we're gonna just jam I'm gonna give
you guys all I got cause we suck at it
because I don't I'm not like we need get
better at so anyway get better that's
what I think
80 euro hello
locating so a lot of influencers I've
been seeing are talking about
they're worried because campaigns aren't
going on right now so their main source
of income is is in a hard place what is
the biggest marketing opportunity for
them right now
that you would give them to build up
their audience for leverage for a
hundred days from today and bring value
so instead of getting selfish and trying
to get money out of their audience bring
better content than ever and I hope to
god that they've been saving their money
unfortunately a lot of influencers that
have been making money have been buying
their Easy's have been taking their spa
days like my number one hope from this
is that people learn how to [ __ ] save
what are you gonna do like what's my tip
what do you mean what my what's my tip
my tip is you should have been [ __ ]
listening because right now people are
scared to spend money yep
what are you gonna beg what do you lower
your rates like what this is there's
consequences you know and the
consequence of you not listening to me
and buying dumb [ __ ] and overextending
yourself and now having nothing to fall
back on is you're gonna be in trouble
you're [ __ ] BMWs gonna be repossessed
[ __ ]
thank you that's everyone G if you could
wrap up the vlog this would be the last
scene of it just you know everyone's
going to the weekend of this like
quarantine week to like everybody's
watching this on Tuesday Wednesday and
after so whenever you're watching this
for probably two three weeks into the
[ __ ] we probably got 2 to 10 more weeks
of this [ __ ]
we probably got another year of it being
a cloud because there's gonna come back
in the fall in winter whatever plays out
just keep your [ __ ] in perspective if
you are fortunate enough to be watching
this right now
and not being somebody who's lost a
loved one because of this or who doesn't
have somebody on a ventilator no matter
how much business you lost back to
Katie's question about like being
answer your restaurant being close money
doesn't mean [ __ ] when you somebody you
love the most in the world dies and so
this is prospective time be grateful for
what you have
don't cry about what's changed it's
devastating for seniors that miss out on
their prom and graduation I understand
that's your world but I promise you
thank God that everybody and your family
is okay focus on the good focus on the
gratitude because if you watch the news
all day if you go on social all day
you're getting into fear something's
[ __ ] that get your [ __ ] mind right
make sure Corona got your mind right
[Music]
okay Gary at vaynermedia say you're
Eddie with the weird background bridge
in the background I'm driving I'm
actually letting you go Gary a
vaynermedia we'll talk soon I think I I
don't think we filled them in that it
was being assumed take blame morning
everybody tea time is tea time I think
we should have a tea palms on tea time
I apologize I was unfortunate not paying
attention one more time like as a with a
thousand person company that basically
went remote before we go any further
like orange orange house but it got
built somehow so I'm just real minutes
fully orange I also like the sweater
like 78 I'm at home when the people go
and see your dance on tick-tock because
I'm waiting I'm sure there's other
people waiting you only you never do the
renegade of something like if I'm a nine
out of 10 or nine point five minute I'm
if I can really rock to another 40 years
of ten out of ten in entrepreneurship
I'm a 1.7 to a two points
except dancing I can do the crab I feel
good about the breakdance with the crab
I might you know what do the crab
tomorrow and try to start that as a
trend as my team do you guys find me a
song that will go well with the crab I
don't know as a crab song but I think
I'm just gonna go [ __ ] go for it
tomorrow so the answer to your question
is tomorrow shrill but the team app I'm
gonna literally film myself doing the
crab and try to get that to be the viral
hit of chicken and by the way if God
forbid it goes viral the fact that we'll
be able to click this moment to that
that that's gonna be another viral post
on on Instagram so we got big stakes and
the answer to your question is tomorrow
cheesecake a cake or a pie cheesecake is
a pie is it I really think when I think
cheesecake like it feels more pie to me
than cakey yep cool I'm more common
sense than you know I'm sure somebody's
gonna reply in the YouTube comments of
like technically the grime like I don't
give a [ __ ] dude
like it feels pie II like I understand
technically the milk or the this I'm
sure there's some reason to define cake
and pie I will say that I am
disproportion see more pie over cake do
you like cheesecake I do like cheesecake
actually I love ricotta cheesecake that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] gnarly but all of you
made these weird faces so now yeah is
that the [ __ ] fancy restaurants that
I go to
that's kind of like no it's funny what a
my favorite my favorite like ice creams
is virgin olive oil and basil like basil
and oil ice cream and then like
everybody always makes face I'm like oh
right they serve those at the bougie
[ __ ] places that I like to go to and
my boo genus comes from the wine
business like all those years being in
the wine business all the events all the
meetings we're always in the top
restaurants so I got real I don't even
even those kind of places no more